Council on Foreign Relations Meeting
Subject: "Pakistan Relations Beyond National
Security Concerns"
Speaker: Hina Rabbani Khar, Minister of Foreign
Affairs,
Islamic Republic of Pakistan
Presider: Madeleine K. Albright, Chair, Albright
Stonebridge Group,
Former U.S. Secretary of State
Location: Council On Foreign Relations, Washington,
D.C.
Time: 10:00 a.m. EDT
Date: September 21, 2012
.STX
(C) COPYRIGHT 2012, FEDERAL NEWS SERVICE,
INC., 1120 G STREET NW; SUITE 990; WASHINGTON,
DC - 20005, USA.
ALL RIGHTS RESERVED.
ANY REPRODUCTION, REDISTRIBUTION OR RETRANSMISSION
IS EXPRESSLY PROHIBITED.
UNAUTHORIZED REPRODUCTION, REDISTRIBUTION
OR RETRANSMISSION CONSTITUTES A MISAPPROPRIATION
UNDER APPLICABLE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW, AND
FEDERAL NEWS SERVICE, INC.
RESERVES THE RIGHT TO PURSUE ALL REMEDIES
AVAILABLE TO IT IN RESPECT TO SUCH MISAPPROPRIATION.
FEDERAL NEWS SERVICE, INC.
IS A PRIVATE FIRM AND IS NOT AFFILIATED WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NO COPYRIGHT IS CLAIMED AS TO ANY PART OF
THE ORIGINAL WORK PREPARED BY A UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT OFFICER OR EMPLOYEE AS PART OF
THAT PERSON'S OFFICIAL DUTIES.
FOR INFORMATION ON SUBSCRIBING TO FNS, PLEASE
CALL 202-347-1400 OR EMAIL INFO@FEDNEWS.COM.
THIS IS A RUSH TRANSCRIPT.
-------------------------
>> MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Good morning, everybody.
Thank you very much for being here, and I
can only assure you that we're going to provide
you with a fascinating discussion.
I also want to welcome the Council on Foreign
Relations members from around the nation and
the world who are participating in this meeting
via teleconference.
On a housekeeping note, please completely
turn off -- not just vibrate, as I tend to
do myself with my cell phone -- to avoid any
interference with the sound system.
And then also please, as a reminder, just
to tell you this meeting is on the record.
Now with all that out of the way, let me say
that how really, really pleased I am to introduce
this woman foreign minister.
I just have to tell you, when I arrived in
New York as our ambassador to the United Nations,
at that time there were 183 countries in the
U.N. It was one of the first times that I
didn't have to cook lunch myself and so I
asked my assistant to invite all the women
permanent representatives to lunch.
And I thought that there would be a lot of
people there.
When I got there, there were six other women.
Because I'm an American, I formed a caucus
and we called ourselves the G-7 -- [laughter]
-- and we did in fact work together very closely.
And when I became secretary of state I created
a group of foreign ministers.
And so at that time there were, like, 14 of
us.
Now there are many, many more.
And so I am very, very happy to be able to
welcome a woman who is part of that group.
Hina Rabbani Khar is a powerful example of
why having more women in senior government
positions is so key.
As the first woman Pakistan foreign minister,
she has joined Benazir Bhutto in blazing a
historic path for women in Pakistan, and she
is taking her country's toughest challenges
at a time of great upheaval and uncertainty
for much of the world.
In a year steeped in heated political rhetoric,
Minister Khar has continued to stress the
critical role that dialogue and diplomacy
can play in resolving regional and global
problems, a sentiment, I think, that many
of us wholeheartedly share.
We're very fortunate to have this chance to
hear from her concerning her perspective on
Pakistan-U.S. relations and other topics that
may be on our minds.
So please join me in greeting our distinguished
foreign minister friend, Hina Rabbani Khar.
[Applause.]
>> FOREIGN MINISTER HINA RABBANI KHAR: [In
Arabic.]
Good morning and asalaam aleikum to everyone.
Let me just say that it is truly a matter
of privilege and pleasure for me to be here.
And for Madam Albright, for you to be chairing
it is of course a matter of honor for me.
And let me acknowledge the role that the CFR
plays in the foreign policy dynamics of your
country.
We hope that Pakistan will also have emerging
institutions which can guide us as we move
forward.
Ladies and gentlemen, I would like to take
the opportunity today to be able to have a
frank and honest discussion because, Madam
Albright, I think increasingly one is finding
out that in our days now almost everything
is on the record.
So even when you're off the record, you're
pretty much on the record.
[Laughter.]
But as we move forward and we talk about Pakistan-U.S.
relations, whether it's beyond security or
the new dynamics of it and the emerging dynamics
of it and what we are able to achieve together,
I think it is important to first talk about
Pakistan itself because I have often said
in the last two days that as foreign minister
of Pakistan I find myself talking more about
what Pakistan is not about rather than what
Pakistan is about.
And I find myself doing that because I think
there are misperceptions about Pakistan, about
Pakistan's intent, about Pakistan's policy
dynamic, about how Pakistan perceives or what
Pakistan perceives to be in its national interest.
The misperception in that runs supreme.
It is -- the misperception so much clouds
our real intent and our real intentions and
our real goals and objectives within the region
and within Pakistan that sometimes it seems
as if Pakistan is quite literally on a suicidal
track, if you were to believe all the misperceptions
about Pakistan which are given to it.
Now, in order to talk about Pakistan, the
potential in Pakistan-U.S. relations, as I
said I think it is important to look at what
Pakistan is today, and even more importantly,
what future Pakistan is marching towards.
And again, I think I often say that what looks
chaotic to the foreign eye is actually a lot
of good happening within Pakistan, a lot of
institution-building happening in Pakistan,
a lot of democracy finding real roots in Pakistan
and democracy starting to deliver.
And I know this question is often asked, how
is democracy delivering in Pakistan, so let
me come straight to that.
This will, inshallah, in the next few months
be the first transfer of power from a civilian
government to a civilian government, under
an election which is held after the 20th amendment
to the constitution, which empowered and made
more independent the election commission of
Pakistan.
This in itself is going to hopefully create
the irreversibility of democracy in Pakistan,
and therefore I no more -- I no longer talk
about civilian governments in Pakistan because
there are only one type of government which
are going to be there in Pakistan.
And what has democracy been able to achieve?
Ladies and gentlemen, in a house which had
a bare majority when it elected its first
prime minister, we have been able to go through
three two-third-majority-requiring constitutional
amendments.
And one of which we are particularly proud
of is the 18th amendment to the constitution,
which brought the 1973 constitution, which
came under Zulfikar Ali Bhutto.
And why was it important?
Because it was a consensus constitution in
Pakistan which brought that back.
Within that constitution another change was
also made, that not only was it required for
all children to go to school but it was now
the responsibility of the state that all girl
and boy children must be educated.
So this is why we have our brawls outside
of the parliament, the political parties in
Pakistan, but when it comes to matters of
national interest the political parties in
Pakistan today have matured to come together
and strive for a future that is better.
What this amendment of the constitution will
also do will correct a lot of historic wrongs
that happened within Pakistan.
Pakistan was conceived to be a federation,
with the provinces having resources and responsibilities.
Over time, with 30-odd years under dictatorial
regimes, we found more and more centralization
of power and resources within the center.
I'm proud to say today that we have decentralized
that, and therefore I don't fear for the future
of our children any more because the resources
today are where the responsibility to teach
them and to feed them and to clothe them and
to give them health facilities is.
Also, in all of this chaos, so to speak, Pakistan
is marching forward with institution-building
like never before.
And I think an excellent example of that is
the free and independent judiciary which sometimes,
you know, there is not very helpful in the
sense that we are proud of the fact that despite
the many challenges that some of these issues,
you know, are faced with, the government is
faced with, the government has marched on
this track to ensure that we have a free,
independent judicial system in Pakistan.
We also have one of the most interesting and
one of the most free media in -- anywhere
in the world.
With 60 channels that are talking mostly about
what government has not been able to do, rather
than what government has been able to do,
I think that also creates a lot of hope for
the future.
I'm now going to talk about the two things
which define what democracy has been able
to do in Pakistan more than anything else,
and the two areas in which I think the results
are already there.
One of those areas is the ownership of our
fight against terrorism.
I don't know how many of you know, but before
this government came into power in 2008, the
perception in Pakistan, whether you read the,
you know, the electronic media or the print
media or spoke to people, was this was the
Western world's war which was imposed on Pakistan
and that Pakistan was fighting somebody else's
war.
It was this government, under the leadership
of President Zardari, which came in and gave
ownership to that war and gave ownership to
that fight, because this was a fight for the
future of our children, certainly with a future
of stability and peace in the region, but
for the future of our children.
This was a fight which was killing our children.
This was a fight which was killing our soldiers.
I don't know how many of you know, but in
the last 10 years Pakistan has lost more than
40,000 people altogether, 40,000 lives in
this fight against terrorism.
In the last five years only we've had almost
352 suicide bomb attacks from 2007 to 2012
inside Pakistan's territory.
And allow me to share with you that pre-9/11
we only had one suicide bomb attack inside
Pakistani territory.
Allow me to share with you that the economic
losses have been colossal, in tens of billions
of dollars.
The estimates are ranging between $75 billion
to $100 billion.
And in all of this, what is most at risk is
a way of life.
What is most at risk is the type of society
that we want to build.
And the biggest fight I think that all of
us collectively must continue to fight is
to fight the mindset which is prevalent amongst
those who try to destroy us.
And in saying this, let me say that when we
talk about the threat and the dangers and
the challenges that Pakistan faces, maybe
-- and certainly a lot of other countries
in the region face also -- but the challenges
that Pakistan faces today have their genesis
in some historical realities, as you said,
Madame Albright, in the unintended consequences
of the decisions that we take many, many years
back.
So therefore, ladies and gentlemen, Pakistan
is very, very aware of the decision-making
of today in how we manage our foreign policy,
how we manage our territory to have consequences
for the future.
And allow me to share with you that what is
happening in Pakistan today in some ways is
a hangover or a leftover from what happened
in our region many, many years back, almost
three decades back.
The arms and the ammunition -- first of all,
let's just talk about what happened over there.
We know that during the Afghan war in the
Soviet era we all collectively -- at least
this country and mine, at least your country
and mine -- collectively chose to harness
religious and what was then the jihadi ideology
to fight the Soviets in Afghanistan as an
instrument of war.
We did that collectively, but it was done
on our soil.
The arms and ammunition, the training that
was given was meant for a purpose.
As the U.S. -- as the strategy succeeded in
Afghanistan, we declared victory and we moved
on.
Some of us were able to move on; the others,
like Pakistan, were left over with the mindset,
with the training, with the arms, with the
ammunition, with the bombs, with the (Kalashnikovs
?), with the narcotics trade, and still today
after three decades we are still suffering
from each one of those.
We are suffering the consequences of each
one of those.
And to me the biggest challenge in all of
this is the mindset that it inculcated, how
it has destroyed our society, how it faces
us as the biggest challenge that we have to
face.
Ladies and gentlemen, in this, from the lessons
that we have learned from the past I think
it is important to apply some of those lessons
as we look at the future.
As we look at the challenges that we face
within the region, Pakistan has grave concerns
over what is going to happen in the future.
We are -- again, I think because I am going
to go and talk a bit about our relations with
Afghanistan and how we view Afghanistan, and
later maybe about our relations with Afghanistan,
allow me to say what we do not want for Afghanistan.
Because as I said, it is not important for
me to say what we do want for Afghanistan.
But what is it that we do not want, which
is particularly -- which is typically ascribed
to Pakistan?
Ladies and gentlemen, first of all let me
say that it is not by -- it is not ambition
but anxiety which drives our interest in Afghanistan.
Allow me to say that we have no favorites
in terms of ethnicities, in terms of groups.
Pakistan today is on a track to develop relations
with Afghanistan as a sovereign equal, and
this to me is a big achievement of the democratic
government in Pakistan.
Pakistan today fears for instability in Afghanistan
because instability from Afghanistan permeates
through the 2,000-plus kilometer border that
we have with Afghanistan directly into Pakistan's
territory, as it has for the last three decades.
There are 53,000 people which cross the Pakistan-Afghan
border every day.
So you can imagine the permeation and the
instantaneous effects of any instability in
Afghanistan.
Allow me to say that we seek no strategic
depth in Afghanistan.
Allow me to categorically say that.
The only strategic depth that we seek with
Afghanistan is friendly; not even will we
seek relations with Afghanistan which are
based on a stable -- on the principle of stable,
peaceful Afghanistan, a sovereign Afghanistan,
an independent Afghanistan.
We have no intention nor any national interest
to impose any type of government in Afghanistan.
It is for the Afghans to do so.
Why all of this is ascribed to Pakistan typically
is because, as I said before, because of the
hangover of the past.
And I think it is important that we are able
to unload the past and move into the future
because I fear that if we are not able to
do that, we will see ourselves inadvertently
repeating the same mistakes.
It will be the consequences of not realizing
reality as it existed.
Now if we look at -- since I was talking about
the ownership of the war on terrorism, and
if we look at the challenges that Pakistan
faces today, very strongly because by no means
we can underestimate them, we are of course
very, very concerned about the state because
we know that the entry goals in Afghanistan
were very, very different from what is appearing
to be now the transition goals.
What we want from the world, what we want
from the 49 nations which are operating in
Afghanistan is that there is no security vacuum
left behind as we go through an exit.
Ladies and gentlemen, for us a few barometers
by which we would look at what is happening
in Afghanistan are the following.
One, until about 2007 we saw a stream, a small
stream but a stream of more than 5 million
Afghan refugees that live in Pakistan going
back into Afghanistan.
Since then, especially since 2009, we almost
see a reverse trend back.
That to me does not bear a lot of confidence.
That to me does not look like we are achieving
the goals that we set out for ourselves collectively.
Recently the incidents that we've had of green-on-blue
attacks and the decision not to go through
joint training, these are all huge concerns
for Pakistan.
These are huge concerns because we will not
be able to change our location.
We will not be able to change our geography.
Because we must make sure that the security
situation in Afghanistan is good enough for
us to be able to build a peaceful and stable
neighborhood.
Recently the third barometer, recently from
the area of -- [inaudible] -- there has been
infiltration in Pakistan territory where hundreds
and two hundreds of militants come inside
Pakistan territory, and as recently as three
weeks back they beheaded, slaughtered 70 of
our soldiers.
All of these are not signs which inspire a
lot of confidence in the security situation
in Afghanistan, and we fear that through the
long border we will have to face more challenges
in the future.
As we move forward, it is important that we
are able to get out of the trust deficit mantra
because, as I say, I have said what is in
Pakistan's national interest and I have said
what is not in Pakistan's national interest.
And allow me to say that what I consider today
to be the primary goal national interest of
Pakistan is a peaceful and stable -- not necessarily
even friendly -- but a peaceful and stable
Afghanistan.
Because we know from history that until and
unless there is peace and stability in Afghanistan,
we will not be able to find our peace and
stability.
And we will not be able to grow economically
the way we wish.
We will not be able to achieve the social
goals for our children that we wish to achieve.
So it is -- we consider it to be in our core
national interest to have a peaceful, stable
Afghanistan and it is time that we put all
our energy together to be able to achieve
those ends.
What is the best possible scenario that we
can think of in 2014?
The best possible scenario that we can think
of for 2014 is that as elections take place
and as transition takes place in Afghanistan,
all Afghan groups are able to demonstrate
their strength, their will through the election
process, not through violence.
And that is a future that we must be working
toward.
That is the immediate short-term future that
we must be working toward.
I'm just going to end by talking a bit about
how democracy has delivered within the region.
I talked to you about our relations with Afghanistan.
Our relations with Afghanistan have not been
easy.
I'm the first one to admit them.
But I want you to consider on what Pakistan
is trying to do with Afghanistan.
When President Zardari was elected as president,
he only invited one foreigner to his inaugural,
and that foreigner happened to be President
Karzai.
In doing that he was sending an important
message.
He was sending a message of respect, a message
of treating each other as sovereign equals.
And he was sending another very important
message, that to Pakistan today the most important
capital in the world is possibly not Washington,
D.C. or London or Berlin.
It is Kabul, because it is in Kabul that our
future is interlinked.
We have suffered through 30 years of instability
and we have seen the negative externality
of combat.
We hope to suffer from the positive externality
or benefit from the positive externally, from
pace and stability in Afghanistan in the next
three decades.
So we have a real interest in ensuring that
there is stability in Afghanistan.
The other area that I want you to concentrate
on is what Pakistan is trying to achieve within
the region, what type of relations it is pursuing
within the region.
Because one thing that is clear to us is that
we will not be able to see peace within if
we do not find peace on our boundaries, on
our borders with our neighbors.
And therefore, ladies and gentlemen, the change
in mindset of approach to a neighbor which
which we've had a particularly hostile relation,
for almost 65 years of our history we have
built on the hostile, negative narrative with
India and they have done the same with Pakistan.
We've all done a fantastic -- both the countries,
done a fantastic job at it.
And we have our issues with India, serious
issues.
The core issue of Jammu and Kashmir is a serious
problem.
It is not a figment of anyone's imagination.
The disputes, the territorial disputes on
Siachen, on -- [inaudible] -- Creek are also
serious problems.
However, what is the way to be able to solve
those problems?
Is it through wars?
Is it through creating a narrative of more
hostility and animosity and filling the minds
of our next generation with the same narrative
that we did of the previous generation?
I think the answer to that is a clear and
simple no.
The way to solve these issues is by building
trust, is by changing the mindset.
Is by building enough trust to be able to
sit across the negotiating table and talk
through these issues and find lasting solutions.
And I will not underestimate the importance
of finding lasting solutions because until
and unless we are able to find lasting solutions
to these issues that we have in India, we
will not be able to disarm the nay-sayers.
So in the last four years what you have seen
is this government pursuing single-mindedly
a track of reaching out to our east, meaning
India, to our west, to Afghanistan, to treating
each other as sovereign equals with respect.
And in doing that, the best message that we
sent India's way is changing a decision that
we had taken and stuck to for almost 40 years.
We said we will not normalize trade with India.
And this government was able to send a message
that we will normalize trade with India.
We will normalize trade with India because
it is important for the economic integration
and trade and investment in each other's countries,
but even more importantly it is important
because we have to invest in building stakeholders
in each other's future, because we have to
start looking at ourselves from a regional
lens and not separate lenses, and it is no
mystery and it is not unknown to any one of
us that it is regions which have emerged -- whether
you look at ASEAN, whether you look at the
European Union, whether you look at South
America -- it is regions which have emerged
economically and otherwise.
So let's just, you know, go to what we feel
is important as we move forward within our
relations with the U.S. A lot is said about
what doesn't work with Pakistan-U.S. relations.
I think a lot less is said about what has
worked for 60 years.
A lot less is said about the fact that the
U.S., for instance, happens to be an investor
in the future of Pakistan.
The alma mater where I come from, Lahore University
of Management Sciences, which I'm proud to
have been a student of, had contributions
from USAID.
And believe me, I went to your colleges also.
LUMS is actually almost better.
So what you helped us create is sometimes
better than some of your own colleges, and
that is the type of contribution that we want,
which is sustainable, which is there to stay,
which is there to be taken on by Pakistani
institutions.
As we move forward we must also understand
that, you know, at least for Pakistan's sake
we are a country with -- you happen to be
our largest trading partner.
You almost happen to be the largest investors
in Pakistan.
There are many things which unite us.
There are many things in which we are stakeholders
in each other's future.
But most importantly, I think without any
doubt what we can achieve together within
the region I feel we have not done justice
to.
I feel that we have let the talk of trust
deficit overwhelm us.
I feel we have not given ourselves a chance.
Allow me to say that if the stated objective
of the United States of America for their
troop presence in Afghanistan is peace and
stability in Afghanistan, then you are pursuing
the national interest of Pakistan, because
the stated and the known and known objective
of Pakistan within the region is also peace
and stability.
Why I talked about the regional approach was
to give you confidence that we are actually
walking the talk of pursuing that, that you
must not look at us from a 30-year-old lens.
That you must look at us from the lens of
today, and the lens of today tells you clearly
that the future that Pakistan wants for itself
is that of peace and stability.
And until and when we have a peaceful, stable
region I think everything else, Madame Albright,
will follow.
So as we march on on a track with the U.S.,
I think we need some -- we need to send each
other messages, and one of the main purpose
of my trip here is to send that message loud
and clear, that we are keen to work together
to ensure that in Afghanistan we are able
to achieve together long, sustainable peace
-- let's admit it -- that we were not able
to achieve 30 years back.
So let's work together.
Let's put our energies together.
Let's put our resources together.
Let's not waste time in blaming each other.
Let's find time to sit together and work through
this together because, as I said, this is
something which is of primary national interest.
So in this relation I think what do the Pakistani
people look for?
The Pakistani people, before anything else,
look for respect, look to be treated as a
sovereign equal.
And this is the respect that we are striving
to ensure is clearly demonstrated in our relations
with Afghanistan also.
We might be the biggest country, we might
be the more resourceful country, we might
be the country with better institutions, but
we must -- for Pakistan I'm speaking -- treat
Afghanistan as a sovereign equal.
And that is what will inspire confidence in
the Afghans.
That is what will give us our strategic depth
in Afghanistan.
So in the same way when you look at Pakistan-U.S.
relations, I think it is important that we
are able to inspire confidence amongst Pakistanis.
And one thing that does come in the way of
us being able to inspire confidence in Pakistanis
is the use of unilateral strikes such as drone
strikes.
Because what that does is, being illegal,
being counter-productive -- most importantly
what it does is that it makes it again your
war and not our war.
It is important that this remain something
that the Pakistanis are striving for for their
own future, and that the Pakistanis should
be allowed to look at it that way.
We expect from the U.S. a deeper understanding
of Pakistan's priorities, Pakistan's concerns,
Pakistan's constraints also because I think
sometimes we are given an overload of capacity.
We are expected to achieve on our side what
49 other countries cannot achieve on the other
side.
So how big do you think we are, or how resourceful
do you think we are?
And most importantly, I think we have of course
always been very grateful for the very strong
message that came from the American people
when you supported the democracy in Pakistan
by again, Senator Kerry, Secretary Clinton
of course had a huge role to play in it.
The KLB was important, the Kerry-Lugar bill
was an important milestone.
It sent a clear message that the U.S. wants
to build long-sustainable relations.
We also feel that a clearer message still
would be recognizing that Pakistan is a country
which has gone through many, many challenges
and therefore a preferential market access
for Pakistani products into U.S. markets.
What that will do is that it will build new
stakeholders in Pakistan.
What that will do is that it will immediately
give the people who today use violence as
means of expressing themselves, it will give
them an alternative.
Really, at the end of the day it is all about
providing alternatives in the type of region
that I come from.
So with those words let me just say that I
hope we have a more interesting discussion
still, and it's been a pleasure, and we hope
that the biggest challenge in front of us
today is what we can achieve together in Afghanistan.
And as we strive towards that, I think in
building these relations we hope that Afghanistan
will not be left in a security -- with
a security vacuum.
[Applause.]
>> ALBRIGHT: Well, thank you very, very much
for that very clear and full statement.
I am not a journalist.
I actually had the same job you have.
And I know what it's like to come to another
country and be subjected to an elite opinion-maker
audience.
And so I -- what I want to get at are some
of the questions of what it's like to actually
carry out foreign policy for your country.
But I can't resist -- you made a lot of news
yesterday.
And among the things you talked about was
the fact that you revealed that there soon
would be confidential talks with the United
States in Afghanistan.
So could you tell us what you're going to
talk about in these confidential talks?
(Laughter.)
>> KHAR: As I said, nothing nowadays is off
the record.
>> ALBRIGHT: (Laughs.)
>> KHAR: But, you know, as I said, I think
-- I think we are truly -- I'm glad that I'm
here when I am.
I wouldn't have wanted to be in Washington
in the last -- before we were able to move
back on rebuilding the relations.
So I feel that today we are in some ways at
a turning point.
I think we have all learned our lessons of
trying to do in Afghanistan what we think
we could achieve.
I think it is important that we are able to
put our energies together, as I said, in the
talks and move to see what we can achieve
together in Afghanistan.
And for that, we already have a system by
which Afghanistan, Pakistan and U.S., a core
group -- in the form of a core group at the
level of the foreign secretaries -- meet.
And they talk about whatever areas and whatever
parts to follow in order to achieve peace
and stability.
For that, of course, reconciliation is a major
element of that.
So we feel that with -- ties with the U.S.
on a positive trajectory, that we have been
able to build enough confidence in each other
to start those serious discussions.
And Madam Albright, the concerns that we have,
of course, are the type that I talked about,
that we may leave behind a security vacuum,
which will come back to haunt us as the one
we left behind three decades back is still
haunting Pakistan.
So it's important that as we look towards
2014 we are able to build an environment whereby
all of one people feel they can express themselves
through the political process.
And that is what we will do whatever we can
to assist our Afghan brothers and sisters.
>> ALBRIGHT: And are they going to begin now
the talks or --
>> KHAR: I think in some ways, you know, this
was already a work in progress, but we have
a much bigger opportunity today than we had,
you know, a few months back to be able to
move on this track.
>> ALBRIGHT: By the way, I'm going to ask
a few questions and then turn it all over
to you.
Let me just say this.
I think that -- first of all, I am among those
Americans who recognize the fact that more
Pakistanis have died from terrorism than Americans
have died or other parts of the world.
The question, I think, that people have is
why is Pakistan not fighting terrorism more
strongly.
Where do we diverge on the methods for dealing
with terrorists?
And why are -- why do we misunderstand each
other so much?
Because I think we do.
I think one of the issues, from my perspective,
is that you said it was very important for
respect.
And yet the sense in following events in Pakistan
and some of the statements is that you see
yourself as a victim, a country that's a victim.
And I just wondered where that difference
comes and whether it is because we see different
methods of fighting terrorism.
>> KHAR: OK.
First of all, why Pakistan has not done enough
is a question that surprises me.
And I think this is where the genesis or the
start of the difference of viewing what we
have done for each other comes from.
You know, I said -- I should have said this
from the podium also.
When I said that this government was able
to take ownership of the fight against terrorism,
one thing that I forgot to share with you
was that when this government came into power,
the total area of FATA that was under government's
control was 37 percent.
Today it is 86 percent.
We had to do two major military operations
and many, many other operations that continue
to happen in Pakistan outside of the headlines
that make it to the -- in Washington Post
or New York Times.
They continue to happen in Pakistan as we
speak, to ensure that we have more and more
area which is completely and directly under
our control.
We feel that the fight we have fought together
against al-Qaida has been relatively successful.
We feel that we have worked together to get
many al-Qaida operators outside -- out of
Pakistan.
So these are things that we have been able
to achieve.
But however, unfortunately, these are things
which are not acknowledged very often.
And we are continuing to find ways and means
of improving our capacity to be able to deal
with this menace as we speak.
And for -- in Pakistan's case, I think mostly
it is a matter of capacity more than intent.
The intent is clearly there.
And that's why my surprise -- because the
intent is demonstrated from the fact that
who did 6,000 of our soldiers die fighting
against if they were not fighting the terrorists?
If we were not doing enough, then how did
6,000 of our soldiers die fighting -- for
what cause were they fighting?
So really I think what is -- what is -- what
is sometimes incorrectly perceived is this
over-projection of capacity on Pakistan's
part to be able to do everything at the same
time.
If in the last four years we have been able
to achieve what we have against terrorism,
I think that is clearly a very, very good
starting point.
And there is clearly more to be done, but
more to be done on two tracks.
One is certainly the operations that you'll
have -- you'll do, you know, whether at the
law enforcement agency level or any other
level.
But the other important one is also be able
to change the mindset.
And for that, the increasing divide between
the West and the East has to stop.
And we, therefore, feel that we are doing
our part in being able to project that within
Pakistan also.
Then you talked about why the misunderstanding.
So I think some of the answers to that I've
already given.
Madam Albright, I'm -- it's interesting that
you talk about a choice between being the
victim and deserving respect.
So when the United States went through 9/11,
the United States was a victim of terrorism.
Your people suffered.
Your people died.
You were a victim.
But you still deserved respect.
Pakistan wants exactly the same thing.
Thirty-three thousand of our civilians have
died.
More than 6,000 of our law enforcement agency
police, military have died, have sacrificed
their lives willingly -- civilians unwillingly,
of course -- people like myself who are indeed
from the elite of Pakistan -- our lifestyles
have changed.
Imagine what it is for the less-privileged
in Pakistan.
The way we have been able to conduct our lives
has changed.
Imagine what it is for the less privileged.
Imagine what it is for the houses of the 6,000
soldiers who have died.
You think any country -- so we say that ask
of us not what you are not willing to give
to everyone.
And look at it as a collective effort.
Look at it as a collective responsibility.
When you look at it as a collective responsibility,
you are able to understand each other's capacity
issues and enhance each other's capacity rather
than blaming each other.
I think we have lost more at the hands of
the -- you know, the trust deficit, quite
frankly speaking, and doubting each other's
intentions than we have at the hands of anything
else.
So, as I said, we are the victims.
We don't want to play the victim.
We don't want to be the victims in the future.
So for that, we need to work together.
And I think despite suffering from this very,
very big menace, we certainly do deserve respect
for each other's sacrifices and respect for
the future that we're trying to build together.
\
>> ALBRIGHT: Let me ask to elaborate a little
bit, because I kind of meant more victim in
terms of not having control over your own
policy.
And one of the things that -- when I was secretary,
I obviously had to consult with the national
security adviser, the Pentagon, the secretary
of Treasury -- it's a decision-making process
-- but ultimately one is part of the decision-making
process.
I wondered -- for instance, you as foreign
minister -- how does it work within your decision-making
process so that you are able to feel that
Pakistan is a partner in a lot of these discussions
so that in fact not -- certainly you are a
victim of terrorism, but I kind of meant victim
of other countries telling you what to do
in your foreign policy and national security
policy.
And then one addendum to that would be is,
we can sit here -- or you will be meeting
with Secretary Clinton, and you can work out
all kinds of things that you might have in
common, but there are events that happen that
are difficult to absorb.
What is the mechanism, or can we all think
about developing a mechanism that deals with
the crisis that makes -- that brings questions
into the decision-making process and also
allows us to have that phone call, to say,
OK, we really do trust each other?
>> KHAR: OK.
First of all, the decision-making process
you talked about -- and you talked about how
as secretary you had to consult and get inputs
-- I think it's pretty much the same.
So this -- if you were alluding to the military
in Pakistan, allow me to say this -- and I'm
saying this on the record, off the record
-- and I would say this, as I said, on the
record and off the record -- the military
in Pakistan has no more a role than the Pentagon
in the U.S.
I don't know what that means now.
I don't know you would --
>> ALBRIGHT: We can talk about that sometime.
[Laughter.]
>> KHAR: Yes.
So allow me to say this with full confidence,
that the military in Pakistan has as much
a role and plays as much a role in the decision-making
process as the Pentagon -- I would think maybe
a little less.
And interestingly, in the last few years,
if you look at what this democratic government
was able to do with the military -- they're
part of the executive, so we must not be able
to look at them -- I think, again, this is
a hangover of the past, and I don't blame
anyone.
I don't blame our people.
I don't blame your people.
If Pakistan was under dictatorial regime for
30-plus years, for 36 years of our history,
of course people are going to ask those questions.
But the military operation, for instance,
that we were able to do in Malakand, in Swat
area of Pakistan, which was able to achieve
rich dividends, was done under the guidance
of the political leadership.
It required for the prime minister at that
time to call in an all-parties conference,
consult all political leaders, create the
space.
That is the way it is done in any other country.
And therefore, we feel that it is important
that everybody takes care of their sphere
of responsibility -- the United States its
own, we ours.
And I'm glad you alluded to the question of
respect vis-a-vis the conduct of foreign relations.
Madam Albright, as -- having served as secretary
of state, I think you're right on spot.
We must all be seen to be pursuing our own
national agenda and our own national interest.
And then the convergence comes.
If we can demonstrate that to the people of
Pakistan, which I'm quite sure is the case,
we would have won this battle and we would
not be talking about the challenges to the
relations between U.S. and Pakistan.
So when I said from the podium that if stability
and peace in Afghanistan is your interest
and the reason for your presence in Afghanistan,
then I see a complete convergence of our national
interest, because stability and peace in Afghanistan
is clearly a core national interest for Pakistan
also.
Then you talked about developing a mechanism
and clarity on that and if there are any incidents.
I think what requires for that is greater
confidence, and I think we are building on
the greater confidence, because there are
many mechanisms that exist at various levels,
but sometimes -- I'm going to steal your phrase
again -- the unintended consequences of the
decisions that we make and the decisions that
we do not make.
For instance, allow me to share with you,
I think it did not have a very good effect
on the Pakistani side --[inaudible] -- inspire
a lot of confidence and mutual respect when
we lost 24 soldiers, and it took a while before
we were able to, you know, say, let's move
on.
It's just things like that which leave lasting
impressions.
And I remember at that time I used to also
say, I do not fear for today; I fear for what
we are doing for tomorrow.
So I think if we have that -- the other thing
that I would like to talk about is -- because
you talked about what would it take -- I think
what it would take, certainly in the case
of Afghanistan -- though I don't like U.S.-Pakistan
relations only to be looked at through the
Afghan lens, but it is true that today the
biggest task that we have to achieve together
is to work together within the Afghan context.
And what will clearly inspire a lot of trust
and confidence is the clarity on what we wish
to achieve in Afghanistan, because, as I said,
the entry goals in Afghanistan are very different
than the goals that we seem to be talking
about today.
I think we need complete clarity on what is
it that we wish to achieve in the next 14,
18 months, and then work backwards from it.
I'm quite sure we will be able to achieve
much more that way.
>> ALBRIGHT: All right.
Let me turn to the audience and -- can you
please rise and tell me your -- identify yourself?
>> QUESTIONER: My name is Peter Baumbusch
-- my name is Peter Baumbusch.
I am a lawyer in Washington.
I'd like to quickly raise three subjects,
which I think are on most people's minds.
The Taliban -- there's a suggestion, at least
by reading the newspapers, that official sources
in Pakistan support the Taliban against U.S.
interest.
I'm not sure that's true.
I'd love your comment.
Second, the Haqqani network -- the same thing;
either it is supported or condoned, its leaders
live in Pakistan without reprisal or problem,
they are killing U.S. soldiers -- that's the
perception.
What is the policy with respect to that?
Third, drone strikes.
I understand the concern of the Pakistanis
that American drone strikes are a difficulty
for Pakistan.
They take away sovereignty and so forth -- sovereignty.
But understand, from the United States' perspective,
they have actually been quite --
>> ALBRIGHT: You've asked three difficult
questions to --
>> QUESTIONER: -- OK -- very effective.
And I'd be interested in your comments.
Thank you very much.
>> KHAR: OK.
I think your first two questions are the same,
because you talked about the Taliban and the
Haqqani Network, and there can be many other
entities, but they're all the same.
If there are any Afghan nationals who are
living in Pakistan -- we have 3 [million]
-- 5 million all together -- I'm just trying
to give you a perspective -- we have 5 million
Afghan nationals who live inside Pakistan.
So we are asked to be responsible for the
activities of some of them.
We have no wherewithal to be responsible -- or
we have no capacity to be responsible for
the activities of 5 million of them, because
there are many, many challenges on this track
that we already suffer from.
But allow me to share this with you clearly
and categorically, that Pakistan -- like any
intelligence agency -- let's be honest with
it -- CIA, any intelligence agency -- to maintain
contact -- CIA has many contacts with many
of these groups also.
So to maintain contact versus having control
-- that's not a very thin line.
But unfortunately, it is always misunderstood
and misperceived.
If we have any contacts with any entities,
our message to those entities is always -- is,
be part of the political process.
And as far as the bigger question of Afghan
presence -- or presence of Afghan nationals
in Pakistan is concerned, I think we need
to find serious answers to that, because we
will be very happy to look for border controls,
for biometric system, for ensuring that as
53,000 people cross the border in and out
every day we can have -- and I'll take just
one minute to give you one example.
I have -- I don't have very good memories
of my last visit to the United States -- actually,
the visit before last -- because as I arrived,
we had a statement -- as I arrived with -- (inaudible)
-- just two days after I had a very extensive
and good meeting with Secretary Clinton, we
had a statement by Admiral Mullen that the
Haqqani Network is a veritable arm of the
United States (sic).
And do you know what inspired that statement?
>> QUESTIONER: ISAF.
>> KHAR: ISAF --
>> ALBRIGHT: (Off mic) --
>> KHAR: -- or maybe -- OK.
That was a -- that was not a Freudian slip.
(Laughter.)
OK.
So what inspired that statement was we were
indeed -- intelligence was shared with us
that there was a truck, which was carrying
some ammo, which was crossing the border and
going into -- and targeting Kabul.
Our intelligence -- that information was shared
with us, and we were asked to apprehend it.
And this was about a 50-kilometer or so area,
where -- within Pakistan.
So we were unable to apprehend it -- as I
said, an overestimation of capacity.
However, my question is that, when it crossed
the Pakistani border and traveled 300 kilometers
inside of one territory, were the Pakistanis
responsible for that?
So how does the onus of all the responsibility
come to us?
So, as I said, I think more trust, more realization
of serious capacity issues, of serious constraints
and working together will obviously help us
move forward.
So we hold no grief -- we hold no love for
any of the entities that you mentioned, anyone
-- any entity, whatever name it carries -- any
entity which uses violence as a means to kill
Afghans is as much a threat to Pakistan's
security, is a threat to Pakistan's national
interest, as those which choose to use violence
against our people.
And believe me, you know, from -- within these
groups, the -- they're very, very -- it gets
very murky as to where the goals and objectives
of one group ends and the other begins.
So we have absolutely no aspiration to -- and
we [are not besotted ?] by any one of them.
The question of drone strikes is an important
one.
And the U.S. claim on that, of course, is
that they're more effective and accurate than
anything than else.
I do not disagree with that maybe they might
be more accurate, they might be more efficient.
But we have to see whether our goal and objective
in all of this fight and all of this war is
to win the battle or concentrate on winning
the war.
Our claim is that we have to win the war,
because we have suffered from the consequences
of what we did three decades back, and we
are still suffering from it today.
And this is just a reemergence of a past mistake.
We don't want the same thing to happen in
the future also.
So therefore, when drone strikes are used,
the message that is sent to the Pakistani
people is that of United States unilateralism,
which is not what it should be and which is
what -- not what it is, which is not the partnership
that we are trying to build.
And I'm very confident today that as we engage
with the United States on this issue and on
others we will be able to find solutions,
because I think the missing link was to just
-- as I said, just -- let's give ourselves
a window of confidence and trust and see what
we can achieve.
I am very confident, if we are able to give
ourselves that window, we will be very unhappy
with the lost opportunity of the last many
months.
>> ALBRIGHT: Yes, sir.
>> QUESTIONER: Thank you.
My name is Mike Haltzel.
I'm at Johns Hopkins SAIS.
Madame Minister, we've been talking a lot
about trust and respect and creating environments
and capacities.
We all know that a vulgar anti-Islamic trailer
was made in California several -- whenever
it was, a few months ago -- and aired, and
it's -- we all know the ramifications around
the globe.
I understand that your government gave a holiday
today to people, saying that it was a way
to enhance security.
Some people think it may have the opposite
effect.
Let me ask this question.
You studied in the United States, you lived
in the United States; I daresay I suspect
you know that the U.S. government is not anti-Islam.
The president, the secretary of state have
put ads on your television, saying that.
Wouldn't it be a good idea for your president,
your prime minister, or even you to go on
television -- you have a lot more credibility
than we do with your own people -- and say,
the United States is an important country
with which we differ on many issues; they
have a different culture; they have a First
Amendment; it may be difficult for us to understand,
but we can assure you they are not anti-Muslim?
Would that not help?
Is that possible?
Wouldn't that create the kind of mutual trust
and respect that you're talking about?
>> KHAR: I think, to be quite honest, there
are two different things, unfortunately, which
are getting mixed up in this particular -- you
know, in this particular problem.
There is one -- let's admit it -- and I think
that this is where we have to have a deeper
understanding of each other's cultures, each
other's religions.
First of all, Islam is a religion of peace.
So this jihadi mindset, which is imposed on
Islam -- let me reject it completely.
Allow me to say also that in Islam, desecration
of any religion -- of any religious figure,
even those of Christianity, even that of Jesus,
and certainly that of Prophet Muhammad is
considered to be wrong.
So I think we need to develop more understanding
in understanding each other's sensitivities.
I am, of course, happy to -- and I know that
many of my other colleagues in Pakistan government
have already done so -- I was just watching,
you know, Information Minister Kaira, who
was saying exactly what you asked us to say,
and I'm happy to say that President -- that
President Obama's words, timely words, Secretary
Clinton's timely words on this are very, very
appreciated.
And they've said that this is disgusting and
that the U.S. government by no means supports
anything like this.
And it is for that reason that in Pakistan
you did not see a reaction in the first week.
But there will always be forces who will use
these opportunities to get their own designs.
And in -- again, I think you need to trust
us with that.
In declaring it a holiday, we think we were
able to manage it better than if it had not.
If it had not been declared a holiday, the
schoolchildren, the office-goers would have
all been at risk.
People would have had more of an opportunity
to congregate.
The type of security measures that the government
was able to take by putting in strong, you
know -- all sorts of things in front of -- diplomatic
missions, et cetera, we think we have been
able to protect our -- and that is our responsibility
to do so.
So, again, let us -- you know, allow us the
privilege of knowing how to deal with a situation
as it arises.
But I think what is important is that on -- we
don't misinterpret this to be entirely anti-Americanism.
This is against one person.
This is against what he did.
And I think -- I have no qualms in saying
this, exactly what you said, that the United
States government's response on this has been
very good.
The United States government, the president,
Secretary Clinton's -- Senator Kerry, as he
met me yesterday, gave a very strong statement
about this, that all of you, the government
feels this is disgusting, that it is not something
that you in any way -- so there's some deeper
issues, but what was required immediately
management.
And believe me, we are trying to manage it.
>> QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Barbara Slavin from the Atlantic Council and
from Al-Monitor.com.
Thank you very much for this opportunity.
You talked about the 24 soldiers that were
killed, but you didn't mention Osama bin Laden.
And many in this country still want to see
a full investigation, to understand how it
was that he lived all that time in Abbottabad
without your government, apparently, knowing
about his presence.
In terms of restoring trust, what are you
doing on this front?
And also, yes, you say that these demonstrations
are against an individual who made a film
and not anti-American, but what can you do
to help Americans feel that they can participate
and help Pakistan when there is a real security
threat to many of them if they try to go out
in Pakistani society?
Thank you.
>> KHAR: OK.
First of all, on Osama bin Laden, as you know,
we have had an independent commission, which
was set up, which is investigating this matter.
And it is surprising, because even though
today's in the age of -- information age and
information travels very quickly, but what
makes headlines here typically -- what makes
headlines in Pakistan typically do not make
headlines -- (inaudible).
For instance, when Osama bin Laden -- it was
found that he was living in that compound,
the reaction from Pakistani society was even
more hostile than maybe yours.
They were even more shocked at it than you.
However, from your intelligence reports -- because
you know a lot of intelligence was gathered
from here -- it is now clear that Pakistani
state or any organ of the state had no knowledge
of it.
However, we are awaiting the report of the
independent commission.
And why we have not said or done anything
on it is because I think we need to give that
process time.
That report is going to be out in October.
And once that report is out, then we will
see, obviously, what needs to be done about
it.
And we are -- we have not -- why don't we
continue to talk about it?
Because I think we need to give that independent
commission the time to be able to deal with
it.
>> ALBRIGHT: I have to ask here -- the treatment
of the doctor, I think, is something --
>> KHAR: Yeah, I know.
>> ALBRIGHT: -- that is of great concern to
many Americans.
>> KHAR: Yes.
OK.
First of all, again, I think there's a serious
communication gap and a difference of how
we view one people or the other.
Osama bin Laden was no hero for Pakistan.
Osama bin Laden -- first let me talk about
-- because I think it is generally believed
that we don't want to talk about Osama bin
Laden because we had -- we almost were harboring
him.
And we -- he was an enemy to us.
He killed -- because of his actions and because
of his organizations, more Pakistanis lost
their lives than maybe 20 other single organization.
We -- as I said before, many al-Qaida operatives
we have been able to go against very, very
effectively.
So he was no hero to Pakistan.
In the same way, we feel Dr. Shakil Afridi
should be no hero to the Americans.
And let me build a case for that.
First of all, it is now well known -- and
I'm sure your own information will corroborate
that -- that Dr. Shakil Afridi did not know
the herculean task that he was trying to do.
He did know that he was going after Osama
bin Laden.
He was a man who was up for hire by anybody
who was willing to pay him, and that included
Islamic organizations, terrorist organizations,
which were using him to move and work against
your and our interests.
So he was no hero.
What we have to do right now is to await the
legal process to take its full course.
And as people who believe in the rule of law,
I think we should allow the process -- he
does have many, you know, ways where he can
go back and take those decisions back -- you
know, appeal processes -- he has many appeal
processes.
Lastly, I am very, very concerned about what
this one man could do to the future of polio
and children in Pakistan.
His activity has ensured that today caregivers
and people who want to work for polio are
not welcomed.
This was a huge battle of 20 years that we
had to fight in Pakistan.
And because of this one single man's activity,
polio today is an emerging concern in Pakistan.
So what I would very much -- and because I
know we're here -- we have people who make
the opinion and therefore the policy, I think
opinion-makers today have more importance
than people like us.
We just have to follow the opinion you create
and somehow deal with it.
So I would urge you to allow -- not allow
this one single man to be the demonstration
of Pakistan-U.S. relations and not to put
-- not to put us hostage to the future of
this.
And I can assure you that he has appeal process
that is available to him.
His lawyers are going through that appeal
process.
Let it run its course.
But let's take this man for what he was.
Let's not valorize a man who may be seen over
here to be pursuing something that he clearly
wasn't.
>> ALBRIGHT: We'll take one more question
in the back there.
>> QUESTIONER: Thank you very much.
(Name inaudible) -- I work for Voice of America,
Pashto -- (inaudible) -- border region.
It's called Deewa Radio.
Thank you very much for your comments.
My question is -- you said that Pakistan-Afghanistan
long border poses also challenges in the future.
So taking into the consideration the Pakistan
role in the future of Afghanistan, especially
talking to Taliban, which also brings into
the fold ISI -- so is it jeopardizing the
Pakistan efforts to play its role, number
one; and second, why do you think that we
don't see any progress on talks with Taliban?
So does it mean they have -- the United States
and Pakistan has differences over the -- how
to reach out to Taliban?
Is that the main reason?
Or what is holding them back?
Thank you very much.
>> KHAR: OK.
Again, something that I referred to earlier,
where I said -- OK, let me talk about this
from the beginning.
Play its role -- I find that this term sometimes
can be misinterpreted, so I don't like to
use this term, that -- what role will Pakistan
play.
I think the role that Pakistan can play is
that of a facilitator, the facilitator of
whatever the Afghan people decide to be the
course of action to take.
And allow me to say that we feel rather strongly
that these peace deals cannot be brokered
anywhere else but in Kabul.
The terms and conditions of these peace deals
also have to be led by Kabul.
So there is maybe a need for more intensive
intra-Afghan dialogue, within their society,
because typically we've seen that efforts
to impose terms and conditions will -- on
the Afghan people have not served our purposes.
So the role that Pakistan can play is only
one role, that of a facilitator.
We are willing to go out of our way to play
the role of a facilitator.
As far as the future of Afghan-Pakistan relations
are concerned, we only wish -- as I said,
we only see strategic depth in having a relation
with Afghanistan -- with an independent, sovereign
(Afghan ?), which are based on trust.
And we are -- our only interest is to have
bilateral relations with Afghanistan as a
sovereign equal.
Because of the past, there will be many misperceptions
on what Pakistan wants to do.
But I can assure you that as we will go through
the next few months and next two years -- and
as you look through the last two years, three
years, ever since this government came in,
I think it should inspire a lot of confidence
in how Pakistan expects to build its relations
with Afghanistan.
>> ALBRIGHT: Madam Minister, thank you very,
very much.
(Applause.)
Your country is lucky to have you as its foreign
minister.
>> KHAR: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
>> ALBRIGHT: Thank you.
MR.
: Thank you very much.
>> ALBRIGHT: Thank you all very much.
####
®FCŻEND
®FLŻ